monsieur bonjour je vends vous
interviewez aujourd'hui pour un chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle signant view on a
été un petit peu témoin de l'actualité à
travers le document on aurait aimé un
petit peu revenir dessus qu'est ce que
vous pouvez me dire un petit peu sur l'
enquête que vous avez menées sur la
banque pasche et le crédit mutuel
d'abord c'est une enquête qu'on a mené
collectivement
s'agit pas d'un sujet que j'aurais pu
faire tout seul dans mon coin mais c'est
un sujet qu'on a fait une enquête qu'on
a mené à quatre ou cinq quatre ou cinq
équipes quatre ou cinq journalistes qui
ont l'habitude de travailler dans le
domaine de l'investigation et jean
pierre est si présent on a été le
rédacteur en chef donc c'est une équipe
c'est une équipe soudée de gens qui
avaient envie de travailler sur ce sujet
et qui en ont tiré une substantifique
moelle assez rapidement ils ont quel
parcours ces gens là c'est
des gens qui ont un intérêt pour
l'investigation depuis longtemps parfois
ils sont jeunes qu'aux jo nous comme
nous geoffrey halilhozic est le co
auteur du film à 28 ans c'est quelqu'un
qui fait de l' enquête depuis le début
de sa carrière
si tant est qu'on puisse parler de
carrière mais en fait il est là depuis
dans le paysage mediapart enquête depuis
cinq six ans déjà et il
et c'est un domaine dans lequel il
oeuvre et où il est bon donc on s'est
associé avec geoffrey livolsi
ensuite on a travaillé
de manière à la fois efficace et rapide
parce qu'il s'agissait au tout début de
l'aventuré de faire un blitzkrieg sur
cette histoire c'est à dire de tournai
raconter et de monter cette enquête et
vérifier les infos et vérifier les infos
en un mois et demi
ces cinq six mois voilà au minimum au
mime au minimum là il se trouve que on a
eu très rapidement des documents on a eu
très rapidement la possibilité de
sécuriser des témoignages qui étaient
ceux des banquiers qui apparaissent dans
le film qui nous ont fait confiance
alors qu'ils avaient refusé jusqu'à
présent de parler à qui que ce soit donc
une fois qu'on avait les témoignages des
banquiers qui ont révélé toute la sphère
au départ qu'on avait une partie des
documents on connaissait les personnages
de cette histoire on a décidé de lancer
la production du film très très très
rapidement pour pouvoir avec l'accord de
canal+ et le soutien de mediapart
diffusé un film dans qui est étayée
sérieux au bout d'un mois et demi et
d'en faire quelques articles sur
mediapart qu'il devait renforcer l'
enquête et ses articles de mediapart au
départ devait être diffusée le 18 mai
dernier au moment où le film jour devait
être diffusée sur canal+
comment vous avez sécuriser vos
informations
en bas c'est très simple on a trouvé des
sources à l'intérieur de la banque
pasche notamment et pas que mes
notamment qui nous ont remis des
centaines de documents d'époque et
papier des documents papier que papier
que papier
que des papiers qui sont de nature
différente ça peut être des prêts ça
peut être des comptes bancaires tout
simplement des opérations financières
sur certains comptes on a donc trier ces
documents on en a tiré quelques
histoires qui nous intéressait mais quel
rabat notamment celle qui apparaît dans
le film c'est à dire ce compte qui
appartient italien qui nous a tout de
suite intéressé parce qu'il s'agit d'un
personnage qu'on avait identifiées
physiquement grâce aux banquiers qu'ils
j'ai vu plusieurs fois et qui ne
représentait pas le profil type du
banquier fin du client de banque privée
quoi en gros c'était plutôt le profil de
la petite frappe italienne
jean baskets grande gueule et bague au
doigt pas tout à fait le genre de
clients des banques privées à monaco si
oui est ce que je veux dire et donc ce
cas là nous a intéressés puisque ce
monsieur
venait à monaco très très très
régulièrement pour déposer de grosse
somme en cash sucre grosse hausse à alet
entre 2000 euros et 60 7000 euros pour
quelqu'un qui était globe qui était
déclarée comme un vendeur de vêtements
sur les marchés en italie et des
versements réguliers avec des versements
très régulier pendant une période assez
courte
et donc on s'est intéressé au personnage
et on a essayé de remonter sa piste
jusqu'à aller en italie dans un marché
où sur un marché où il l'aurait dû
travailler en allemand on a remonté sa
pige jusqu'à comprendre et l'avoir
directement au téléphone pour comprendre
qu'il s'agissait en fait d'un chômeur
qui compte de paye un homme de paille en
tout cas il on ne connaît pas
véritablement sa profession un mot il
fait envoyé spécial en tout cas c'est
quelqu'un qui a dû travailler pour
quelqu'un d'autre sûrement mais on en
n'a pas la preuve formelle
organisation peut-être ou peut-être une
organisation alors après s'agit d'une
action criminelle mafieuse ça on n'en
sait rien en fait on n'a pas la preuve
on aurait aimé le rencontrer on a fait
il rencontrait d'ailleurs mais il a
refusé au dernier moment par les ont lus
à parler au téléphone plusieurs fois
dans le film apparaît l'une des
dernières conversations
avec lui et ce monsieur a été assez
agressif
pour nous menacer assez rapidement de
nous casser bras il a eu peur il n'a pas
eu peur on sait que nous il a eu peur
peut-être des gens avec qui il a fait
refaire pour lesquels il a travaillé
donc c'est un métier compliqué quand
même journaliste à une autre époque et
vous avez eu des petites des petites
histoires un peu et canal+ alors comme
l'a expliqué nicolas nous avons sommes
partis la fleur au fusil début avril
faire cette enquête on avait déjà
beaucoup d'éléments en main et on a eu
la bonne idée de s'associer avec
mediapart sur ce coup là puisque
mediapart avait déjà commencé à
travailler sur le sujet geoffrey livolsi
qui avait déjà commis quelques articles
sur le sujet et donc ont très nettement
au début on a évidemment travailler que
l'équipe de spécial investigation qui
était ravi de voir arriver une enquête
avec déjà pas mal d'éléments à ramasser
aggloméré par un parent par nicolas et
par geoffrey livolsi et ce qui nous a
permis d'imaginer de faire cette enquête
en un mois et demi et puis en fait très
très vite au bout de quelques semaines
moi j'ai eu
sa formation sont arrivés de la part de
mon patron de la boîte de prod quand
même mon patron qui travaille
régulièrement avec canal et qui m'a
expliqué que ce sujet commencé à poser
problème en haut lieu à canal+ de
spécifier tout de suite le haut lieu oui
oui bah oui parce que c'est un patron
qui est clair et qui me dit les choses
d'ailleurs je salue à nouveau encore son
sac l'art c'est dans tout ça parce qu'il
a jamais c'est tourner autour du pot on
s'est dit des choses très vite et donc
moi je voulais dire une chose très
simple j'ai dit écoute je
l'investigation temps n'a pas fait toute
ta vie l'attend fait depuis quelques
années puisque nous sommes ici pour en
faire moi j'ai jamais eu l'habitude de
me censurer ni les équipes etc lesquels
je travaillais donc une fin en soi et de
femmes oui tu as des enfants oui
pourquoi
non mais on est aussi quand même dans
une démocratie il faut la faire vivre
ces démocraties et si nous sommes un
contrat qui croient encore à moi j'y
crois oui bien sûr j'y crois parce que
je pense que c'est important de en fait
c'est le fait de la faire vivre à notre
niveau nous on est journaliste donc
notre niveau c'est d'être un
contre-pouvoir nous sommes restantes en
par contre c'est à dire que nous vont
nous empêcher les pouvoirs ont dit on
dit le pouvoir corrompt le pouvoir
absolu corrompt absolument c'est une
phrase bien connue nous nous sommes là
pour empêcher que ce pouvoir soit
corrompu nous sommes là pour aller
mettre notre nez là où on nous dit de ne
pas aller pour que le citoyen soit
informée c'est assez simple sur le
papier après dans les fait appliquer ce
travail là bas ça nécessite d'abord
d'être en confiance de travail et
rationnellement vérifier ces
informations de prendre le temps et puis
de trouver des diffuseurs mais après ça
c'est une autre histoire georgi trouve
que
tu trouves que journaliste maintenant
c'est compliqué parce que tu penses que
la laisse du pouvoir ce temps sur le
collier des journalistes plus que
d'habitude je crois que c'est cyclique
tu touches à certains sujets je crois
que c'est cyclique
je crois qu'il ya 20 ou 30 ans c'était
plus le pouvoir politique qui avait de
l'influencé sur les journalistes
clairement alors je parle de la france
parce que les cas sont différents en
angleterre aux etats unis le 4 les cas
sont très différents mais en france
était plus le pouvoir politique qui
avait qu'arriver à mettre de son côté
des journalistes aujourd'hui c'est
clairement le pouvoir économique on est
clairement aujourd'hui dans une ère
facettes j'enfonce une porte ouverte où
les où les grandes multinationales ont
un pouvoir politique supérieur à
beaucoup d'états pas toujours des
méchants google jusqu'à présent n'a pas
encore conquis le monde d'un point de
vue politique mais en tout cas c'est ce
que celle des pays
non en fait en fait je sais que tu veut
m'emmener tu veut m'emmener sur le sur
la prééminence des étapes de ce que moi
j'appelle les états privé c'est à dire
les multinationales sur sur les états
les états pas du tout ce regard là j'ai
un regard c'est les gars fatigue google
facebook c'est utilisé comme une pointe
de diamant pour accumuler de la data
simplement des pailles aps c sous
couvert dont on va vous fournir un
service extraordinaire vous avez venir
clients et nous comme on est très gentil
on va récupérer toutes vos données et
ainsi de suite c'est on est complètement
dans cette problématique là on est dans
d'autres problématiques quand il s'agit
du groupe bolloré revenons au
journalisme mais en tout cas ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'aujourd'hui ta
question est est ce que des journalistes
sont en laisse entre guillemets ou en
tout cas susceptibles de l'être par des
pouvoirs moi je pense oui par des
pouvoirs économiques bien plus que par
des pouvoirs politiques pouvoir
politique étant largement affaiblie
aujourd'hui par rapport au pouvoir pour
économique voilà mais c'était une
personne faire poser une question
indiscrète je te remplace l'amour de
suite
est-ce que tu as une stratégie
financière par rapport aux sujets que tu
peux être amené à enquêter c'est à dire
ce que tu dis voilà c'est un sujet on va
traiter par exemple de l'anthrax tu vois
les espèces d'antilopes qui ont été
envoyées
dit tu tombes sur un gros renard est
quand même le gouverneur il a capté il
est capable de te faire très très mal
sur ta carrière professionnelle tu dis
voilà je suis capable d'encaisser
cinq ans de 50 procédure est ce que je
suis capable d'encaisser dix ans de
procédure bâillon ou est ce que c'est
quelque chose que tu réfléchis dès le
départ donné ça c'est clair que quand on
fait de l'investigation il faut se poser
cette question une fois clairement un
pas encore l'écho aussi nécessaire quand
on fait de l'investigation il faut
clairement a souri le fait des tensions
annoncées au cas où oui alors depuis
longtemps on travaille maintenant depuis
longtemps avec des juristes ou des
avocats spécialisés dans le droit de la
presse qui avec qui accompagne une
enquête et avec lesquels on verrouille
nos infos et avec lesquels on bétonne ce
qu'on va mettre à l'antenne la bbc fait
ça depuis des dizaines d'années le
nouveau open space de la bbc par exemple
y compris pour le news vous avez une
armée de juristes quatre ou cinq en
permanence 24 heures sur 24 qui
conseille les journalistes dès qu'il
s'agit d'un petit sujet un petit peu
cheap conscience et s'appelle conseillé
à l'ordre c'est un juriste me concernant
je voyage je fais quand même vachement
gaffe une bonne question il est il est
courant et du courant il arrive que des
juristes dans l'est dans les chaînes de
télé soit plutôt castrateur sur le
niveau de révélations et donc il s'agit
donc de trouver des juristes ou des
avocats qui ne soit pas castrale
castrateur qui soit aussi que subsiste
une journée voilà dans là dedans
l'arrivée dans la volonté de révéler
mais qui équipent arrière soit très
sérieux sur le fond en gros c'est
vraiment ça et ça c'est des c'est vrai
que c'est des personnages qui sont assez
rares bon nous on en a eu une pas loin
de nous qui s'appelait virginie marqué
cayla la lune d avocat très actif dans
le dans le collectif informer n'est pas
un délit et qui est très pointue là
dessus et qui accompagne enquête voilà
je reviens sur toi nico ouais tu voulais
en venir sur quelque chose mais enfin tu
parlais de l'ess au coût des
journalistes en fait pouvoir la laisse
du pouvoir moi je crois que beaucoup de
nos confrères sans vouloir taper sur nos
confrères
non pas besoin de l'ess en fait c'est
que le problème vient de là c'est que
quand vous travaillez dans un journal
économique vous savez que vous ne pouvez
pas
intervenir enquêter sur tout un tas de
sujets quant à pain ou de termes pour
appeler ça comme on appelle ça dans
l'es5 de reina qui vers l'auto censure
l'autocensure c'est là le plein c'est la
plaie de notre métier des monges bull
quoi c'est pas des manches bull sait qu'
il peut y avoir des journalistes de
qualité ils font sérieusement leur
boulot mais qui ne vont pas sur des
terrains parce qu'ils savent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas pourquoi parce que leurs
actionnaires ces trésors interne que tu
me racontes c'est très intéressant est
ce que tu penses que c'est le syndrome
du larbin
tu sais ce que c'est le syndrome du
larbin là je le syndrome du larbin sion
la soumission consentie la soumission
oui il ya sûrement de ça effectivement
il ya sûrement de la soumission
consentie et quand on accepte de
travailler pour quelqu'un on en accepte
aussi l'auguré les règles quand peu
taillé pour pour bernard arnault ou pour
monsieur pinault pour monsieur dassault
quand vous travaillez au figaro vous
savez que vous ne pouvez pas être
critique sur les les actions de monsieur
dassault honni en politique ni de point
de risques et périls ou s'il suffit
d'égratigner un poil le rafale et c'est
terminé et votre papier ne passera pas à
vous le savez donc quand vous le savez
et ben vous faites pas votre paquet sur
le rafale et c'est l'une des plaies et
nous avec jean-pierre on a on a eu la
chance jusqu'à présent de travailler
pour des boîtes qui prenait la
responsabilité et avec jean pierre tu
parlais justement de risques que l'on
prend on n'évalue pas les risques en
termes d'années de procédure qu'on va
devoir se payer après un sujet diffusé
on évalue les risques sur l'info est ce
qu'on peut aller est ce qu on a les
éléments pour dévoiler une info et
femmes est-ce qu'on a les preuves
ensuite si on a les preuves et c'est le
cas pour le crédit mutuel on va jusqu'au
bout de notre enquête est on est on
assume en fait les risques de à tous
points de vue car qu'on défend notre
enquête et on n'en défend les
conclusions c'est normal c'est la
quintessence même de ton boulot c'était
presse sacrifier non je me dis que si
ton enquête et béton
si tu es assis des fondations stables
que t as triangle est ton information
béton béton béton tu ira jusqu'au bout
mais je vois pas pourquoi on n'irait pas
jusqu'au bout parce qu'il a décollé
comme c'est compliqué quand on sait que
l'ags est une espèce rare qu'on ne
vendait pas des espèces alors on est on
n'est pas en train de chauffer ma nous
ériger on n'est pas du tout on évalue à
10 un hôtel de la dévotion je veux dire
qu'on fait enfin c'est simple en fait je
vais revenir sur un point qui moi me me
semble important sépare donc je crois
pas au journalisme d'investigation je ne
pense pas qu'il ya des journalistes
d'investigation
je pense qu'il ya des journalistes qui
font leur boulot qu'ils font leurs
enquêtes qui vont jusqu'au bout et
qu'ils défendent des principes ou des
valeurs le journaliste d'investigation
qui serait drapé dans une cape
d'investigation et que un rôle majeur
par rapport à toute autre journaliste
non il ya des journalistes il ya des
journalistes qui font de l'enquète et
qui ont la volonté d'aller au bout de
leur enquête mais il n'y a pas deux ne
sert qu il ya un journalisme
d'investigation ça n'existe sert qu'à ça
donc donc là il se trouve que mal beau
rôle parce que on vient de livrer une
enquête qui a vu une diffusion entre
parenthèses sincèrement merci le service
public il ya eu deux il ya eu des années
où ce très beau cadeau pourquoi non mais
ce que je veux dire par là non mais
merci parce que c'est important parce
que là pour nous on a eu un diffuseur
nous si on n'avait pas eu diffuseur on
aurait trouvé des solutions quel type
omar je sais pas des gens auraient pu
diffuser ce sujet depuis la belgique ça
touche le jeune loup
tiens tiens je reviens je reviens j'ai
attend juste une question essentielle
sur la posture parce que ce que dit nico
est important je crois que c'est un
pléonasme journaliste d'investigation
est ce qu on fait notre boulot ou pas à
quoi on sert on sert qu'à ça si c'est
pour tout casser les jambes sedano blanc
oui mais du coup je veux pas faire de la
philosophie de comptoir mais albert
camus est concerné dans notre enquête
albert camus il a écrit là il a beaucoup
réfléchi à l'homme révolté bon ben voilà
ce sont des questions personnelles tout
ça quand vous faites journalisme il faut
être un homme révolté non pas contre
tout et n'importe quoi il faut se
positionner par rapport à une
problématique est notre manière d'y
répondre à nous est de ramasser des
infos de les faire parler et d'en tirer
une conclusion c'est ça notre boulot est
de le porter sur la place publique pour
que les gens vous tous à nous tous
puissent cette mission avoir un avis sur
une question majeure sauf l'artiste
qualité par la différence entre
quelqu'un qui travaille dans une chaîne
d'info en continu et pourtant j'y ai
travaillé donc je sais exactement
comment ils bossent c'est que nous bon
le temps et les moyens de pouvoir
réfléchir de pouvoir bosser de mettre
les choses en perspective la plupart de
nos confrères 95% de nos confrères n'ont
pas le temps de faire ça donc c'est à
dire qu'ils mangent des racines en fait
et c'est à dire qu'ils font ce pourquoi
leurs médias les emplois c'est à dire
faire une pirouette ils sont payés
parfois avec nadia k way les jeunes
combien vous toucher vous nous on est
relativement bien payer pour ce que l'on
fait c'est vraiment pas une question tu
veux savoir exactement mon salaire pif
au pif moi je te le dis je gagne à peu
près 4000 euros net par mois ou encore
en tant que cdi d'accord moi en tant
qu'adepte ans j'ai six mille mais en cdd
mais en cdd ça tu peux sauter du genre
en trois un coin cuisine 40 40 ans donc
je suis de 40 ans la moyenne aux
journalistes sais combien vous savez à
peu près un jeune français les en télé
alors
on va démarrage c'est ça le prix d'un
gardien de la paix quoi on va être en
tous cas c'est aussi un prof qui les
équidés marque un prof qui démarre sa
gagne 1500 euros à peu près net par mois
un jeune journaliste qui démarre et qui
va faire deux ans de dsk sur une chaîne
d'info il va gagner à peu près ça avant
de pouvoir évoluer votre enquête ça
coûte et combien en un mois et demi un
budget d'une enquête classique en télé
cercle sur sur cinq six mois de travail
un 52 minutes ses tresses et très
calibré sur les grandes chaînes de télé
entre france 3 et canal+ on est entre
80000 et 110 mille euros de budget donné
par la chaîne ça vous parle peut-être
sans doute pas il ya du cnc là dessus on
rajoute 20 à 30000 euros de scène c'est
donc ça fait grosso modo on va dire
allez 130000 euros en moyenne ce qui est
ric-rac pour bien bosser pas et c'est
pas non plus le cheap mais c'est quand
même c'est pas nouveau les grosses
sommes pour travailler vous avez vite
grillé en voyageant recoupements plus
l'investigation ça rapporte pas d'argent
enfin les marches de 20% que les
moniteurs rêve de faire une
investigation c'est pas facile je vais
vous poser une question de l'état à
l'état par l'intermédiaire nous impose
de nous beaucoup d'argent de subventions
à des journaux tout le monde y touche je
crois même télé z d'en toucher si c'est
encore
quand vous avez cinq organes de presse
détenue par des parrains du business
quand ils touchent en plus de l'argent
du service public et que tous les sujets
ne peuvent pas être portée d'une façon
équitable vous ça vous fait quoi ça nous
fait réfléchir ça nous fait réfléchir
sur la concentration des médias et c'est
une des plaies à par l'autocensure de ce
métier là si vous avez des intérêts
concentré dans quelques mains il ça veut
dire que quelques mains détiennent
beaucoup de pouvoirs sur énormément de
journaux de télévision et de radio la
concentration à l'heure actuelle c'est à
peu près quoi pourquoi moi je ne
pourrais pas disons de donner un chiffre
je veux dire je peux pas vous dire donc
si on regarde à peu près les dits
industriels français importants qui sont
investis dans la presse avec ces dits
industriels là vous avez plus de 50 % au
minimum de la presse concentré dans dix
paires de mains est ce que ça te fait
penser un peu comme en corée du nord tu
sais les haut parleurs qui ne nous était
jamais en corée du nord et la corée du
nord c'est autre chose que ce que la
focus nord mais en revanche j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur la corée du nord
n'avait pas été bon mais je je je
connais pas mal ce petit régis corp donc
tu vois à peu près le régime ce petit
régis ouais tu as peu près la propagande
ex du monde ex union soviétique un peu
la chinoise au tibet c'est à dire
répéter toujours la même chose toujours
avec le même teint de voix avec son
corps est ce que tu penses que le fait
que ces médias soient tellement
concentré tu peux y avoir tu peux avoir
un alignement sur certains sujets comme
ce que vous avez égratigné par
l'intermédiaire des évasions fiscales et
quand ça commence vraiment à toucher à
pic et vous avez là l'opportunité de
vous faire blacklister blackboulé ou
d'avoir une guerre informationnelle
contre votre reportage ouais est-ce que
ça peut quand même commencer à peser sur
la république est-ce que ça a été le cas
pour nous
on a travaillé vite et j'espère bien on
n'a pas eu de pression à subir de qui
que ce soit jusqu'à en fait la pression
finale c'est à dire que le film a été
retiré par un monsieur bolloré qu'il y
ait une pression pas mal ce qui est une
pression finale mais tout le tout au
long de l'enquète on nous a pas on ne va
pas emmerder nous allons n'est pas venu
chercher des noises dit simone
concentration des pouvoirs être un
problème oui c'est un problème quand le
pouvoir est trop concentrée entre les
mains de quelques-uns ça pose problème
ça pose des problèmes démocratiques
ça pose des problèmes aux journalistes
qui ne peuvent pas souvent faire leur
boulot convenablement même s'ils veulent
le faire on en revient à l'autocensure
donc je te résume d'après ce que j'ai
essayé de comprendre
pour vous avez un peu de bouteille vous
touchez quand même correctement votre
vie parce que l'on a autour de 40 45 ans
vous êtes à votre vote apogée de votre
pouvoir d'achat
là dessus il ya des jeunes journalistes
qui sont un petit peu soumis à une
contrainte financière de jeu de
rembourser mon prêt et qui m'ont emprunt
étudiant j'ai un gamin noisy ingestion
d'eau rembourser
donc le tu dois tu as une contrainte
financière très importante donc cette
soumission de par le stress de se
retrouver avec une tension financière
sur son compte en banque et la fin du
mois
sacré on va dire un auto censure pire
que autocensure et tes pronostics sur
des sujets un petit peu comme l'armement
la guerre est ce que tu penses que les
sujets de type géopolitiques sont
traités à la juste hauteur à peu près
que ton sujet sur la réunion
c'est très compliqué de répondre à cette
question est ce que c'est une habitude
de la chaîne est ce que c'est mais la
réponse n'est pas facile à part ce que
est ce que en gros tu as question c'est
est-ce qu'on a suffisamment de moyens où
on accorde suffisamment de moyens à des
sujets qui sont majeurs ou est ce que
les journalistes sont pas suffisamment
formaté dans les écoles pour éviter
d'être un peu comme vous un petit peu
des vrais et pas des têtes brûlées mais
au moins tu fais ton boulot avec le
coeur qui va jusqu'au bout ouais je te
comparer à denis robert tu vas devenir
la conversion en 2013 c'est un mec c'est
un ovni que quand tu le rencontres tu
comprends que le gars il était c'était
jésus il allait traverser les océans
pour aller chercher la justice l'équité
parce que c'est dans son sens c'est dans
son sang mais moi je ne veux pas faim je
sais pas si jean pierre
je ne suis pas jésus non moi
mais ce que je veux dire on est là pour
on n'a pas de comptes à régler avec avec
qui que ce soit moi je n'ai pas de
comptes à régler avec la population est
ce que tu vois comment tu as pu entacher
avis tu dis ça sur internet a
l'impression de dire croque mort lorsque
je veux dire c'est que j'ai pas de
comptes à régler avec ni monsieur
bolloré ni monsieur dassault n'est
monsieur pinault dit monsieur arnaud
ces gens là s'ils font bien leur métier
ils n'ont donc rien à craindre de
quelques enquêtes que ce soir mais ça tu
passes un peu sur le postulat bisounours
que non c'est pas le postulat
bizarrement je crois que tu crois c'est
que patron de super patron si t'as pas
eu quelques petits procès derrière toi
je ne sais pas ce que je veux dire c'est
que moi je n'ai de comptes à régler avec
personne ne méritait pas de régler des
comptes c'est d'essayer d'avoir des
infos et des démonter des systèmes et
des mécanismes zénith ce que fait ce
qu'a fait très bien denis robert et
c'est comme ça que moi j'envisage mon
boulot c'est pas je ne me paye pas
bolloré alors je ne peux paye pas
d'assaut ce que je sais c'est de
comprendre j'ai compris j'ai compris sur
la table à fond qui fait pas investies
n'était pas investi je pense que 2010
lui n'était pas investi d'une mission
grimpera naturel tu soulèves quelque
chose de très important c'est à dire ton
travail de vulgarisation de
l'information
moi je vais poser une question très très
dur est ce que tu penses que ton public
le public français n'a pas passé le
point de non-retour quant à sa capacité
de déchiffrer et comprendre la formation
c'est dire qu'à l'heure actuelle on est
dans une société d'instantanéité que
tout ce qui est long dur et aride est
traité d'une façon relativement
superficielles par toute une caste
journalistique
je résume trivialement mais dans la main
dix personnes et en face tu te retrouves
des téléréalités tenais à la neuvième
saison de j'ai des gros seins à la télé
et ça fait marrer tout le monde alors ça
parle de l'évasion fiscale ray est ce
que tu penses que ta population enfin
c'est suffisament encore ticket pour
être à ton niveau alors
la réponse à ça à mon avis elle vient de
d'une simple et d'une simple chose c'est
que le film qu'on a réalisé avec jean
pierre et d'autres sur le crédit mutuel
est passé à 23h30 sur france 3 il a duré
55 minutes il a été suivi d'un plateau
la chaîne france 3 a fait son record
d'audience à cette heure-là depuis
qu'une demande 4 5 ans ça veut dire
qu'il ya une demande
du public pour des enquêtes qui sont
fouillés étayé et sérieuse les gens ils
veulent comprendre pourquoi ils veulent
comprendre tout simplement parce que
dehors il ya une crise économique et qui
à un moment donné le foutage de gueule à
tous les niveaux habituels incontri
auteuil alors être crise économique on
est sorti de la crise économique dans
l'est bien longtemps que j'arrive à
mieux vous les gens sont dans une sont
dans une phase de crise ce soit au
niveau personnel au niveau professionnel
et qu'à un moment je pense que les gens
ils en ont assez qu'on se foutait de
leur gueule
que certains ou certaines personnes
soient privilégiés et que eux la seule
chose qui voit au quotidien c'est qui on
leur tape dessus en permanence alors il
ya des réponses politiques ça parce
qu'on est en démocratie on peut voter on
peut choisir nos élus mais au point de
vue économique nous ce qu'on fait avec
jean-pierre c'est qu'on essaie de
démonter les mécanismes procès de faire
comprendre aux gens certaines choses et
délivrer nos enquêtes est-ce que tu as
que vous avez poussé le démontage de ce
mécanisme est ensuite est-ce que vous
avez cherché à remonter un peu le
principe à coeur c'est à dire qu'on
démonte pour apprendre à me remonter
peut être optimisé et peut-être
extrapoler est-ce que vous avez
extrapolé en fait le le phénomène
d'évasion ou d'optimisation fiscale
est-ce que ce qu'elle quelles sont vos
conclusions par rapport à cet extra peur
là dessus c'est un travail long et il se
trouve que ça dry long parce que en fait
pour rôle moi je pense par envoi la
cartographie d'évasion fiscale la
cartographie de la meinau fiscale c'est
clair que les journalistes seuls peuvent
pas le faire donc il vaut sec des
hackers des hackers évidemment qu'ils
ont la conscience de révéler comme sans
doute ici
avec des datas journalistes il faut
qu'il bosse ensemble parce qu'on est
beaucoup moins intelligent tout seul on
est beaucoup plus intelligent
collectivement et là en ce moment même
je peux vous le dire clairement et pas
qu'en france il ya des travaux qui sont
menés qui connaîtront une traduction
concrète dans quelques mois sur toutes
ces questions là d'essayer de comprendre
le système globalement parce que nous
sommes en capacité aujourd'hui via le
web via les outils de data journalisme
de recrutement de recherche dont nous
disposons pour cartographier tout ça ce
travail est en cours il prend du temps
parce que c'est un travail ne serait ce
que nous quand on travaille sur un
groupe et à quelques temps
nicolas avait travaillé sur sur l'empiré
des mulliez ce qui possède les enseignes
auchan qui vont ils passer par une
quarantaine d'enseignants france et
c'est une organisation très très très
complexe de familiale 600 membres de la
famille possède l empire bien réels déjà
cartographier ça ça prend des mois
cartographier l'évasion fiscale au
niveau mondial parce que c'est par
essence au niveau mondial ce travail là
est en cours il a des relais au guardian
il a des relais où elle siège est à
washington il a dévoilé à paris les
rôles et à singapour et c'est un travail
c'est ça c'est la bonne nouvelle en fait
c'est que les journalistes qui sont
envie de travailler quand vite cherché
commencent à se fédérer au plan
international largement de plus
wikileaks on connaisse salma la marque
historique et s'associe avec des hackers
des blogueurs n'y a pas qu'une
confrontation entre les hackers les gens
restent heureusement ça commence
vraiment maintenant à à ceux qui font
correctement leur travail correctement
il ya une demande pour ça il ya une
vraie demande mais juste par rapport à
l'audience je peux pas parler dans mon
ancienne boutique cash investigations on
a bataillé pour faire un prime sur
france 2 avec de l'évasion fiscale ce
qui allait devenir plus tard le luxe
leaks on a eu plusieurs millions de
téléspectateurs le match lorsque les
russes et ça va essayer les yeux cernés
par moody's du sel à plusieurs millions
de téléspectateurs 2 et 3 millions le
crédit mutuel on a eu un million de
téléspectateurs et ne demanderez à 23h30
bois 23h30 souvent je suis couché est ce
que je suis crevé et bien là il y avait
un million de personnes devant la devant
la téloche pendant des années on a
entendu dans les chaînes de télé dans
les boîtes de prod l'investigation
s'emmerde tout le monde les gens n'y
comprennent rien ils ne veulent pas d'un
engin à nana mais si quand on leur
explique quand on prend le temps de
l'expliquer c'est pas sorcier voilà le
vous n'êtes cette émission c'est pas
sorcier il a calqué la calquer
investigations vous êtes parti quoi
voilà les gens viennent ce qui
comprennent les choses alors ça va être
compliqué de formuler mes questions tu
parles d'une demande tu parle de
technique chez de cartographie de
bécancour c'est d'accord
c'est en gros ce n'était pas ton rôle
toi tu es tunis simplement aucun c'est
vraiment symptômes des symptômes c'est
là que tu t'es sorti libre à des postes
a dit ok bon alors 5 ans appartient un
peu en sucette on va développer des
outils on va saluer des compétences en
gros tu a monté une cellule
la question je te pousse et tu crois pas
que ton état en face de toi qui as a big
data qui est capable de tracer les flux
financiers qui à swift qui tu prends pas
que cet état qui fait aussi des fois
l'utilisation de paradis fiscaux toutes
les banques je sais pas je m'avance peut
être un peu je perds je parle sous votre
contrôle mais toutes les banques ont des
filiales dans des paradis fiscaux toutes
les brutes et ut baladé un petit peu
dans les caraïbes je te conseille bornes
alors oui je connais pas transiger c'est
extraordinaire sur l'italie que c'est
pas mal non plus en plus de la caisse du
réseau spécifique sur les banques est ce
que ça te fais comme tu es quand même tu
as l'air un petit peu opérationnels au
niveau du numérique parce que tu parles
d'utiliser des tatas journalistes un
titre m à une passer un petit bonjour je
ne suis rien
jean-marc ton boulot l'état a déjà des
outils
beaucoup la question que je me pose
c'est à ton avis pourquoi ils attrapent
personnes je retourne la question il a
30 ans ma personne ah et on va leur
donner juste un tout petit bon point
depuis qu'on a des prêtres et chirac
géant depuis lors il ya quand même
quelques milliards qui ont été
récupérées là par le fisc français de
meilleurs prix souligne le camp même de
mieux que rien c'est pas les 50
milliards qui nous échappent chaque
année mais il ya quelques milliards 2
milliards qui ont été récupérés de la
dernière depuis deux ans voilà depuis
que le fisc a noué des accords un peu
plus direct avec la suisse que le secret
bancaire est tombé par exemple il sait
rien du tout l'équité face pour
l'instant face à la fiscalité face à l'
équilibre entre une multinationale et
vous et moi c'est rien du tout
évidemment qu'un travail colossal à
mener c'est un problème purement
démocratique pourquoi l'état fait pas ce
travail
c'est pas sans doute que on considère
que les intérêts économiques que
représentent les entreprises sont
prioritaires à court terme plutôt que la
récupération de cet argent on pourrait
considérer si on avait une vision à long
terme que mettre tout le monde au pas
que les multinationales se loger à la
même enseigne qu'un citoyen de base ça
permettrait construire à long terme bien
plus de manière bien plus solide mais
c'est très utopique désaccord
transatlantique ça te parle un peu bien
sûr d'amendé à sa langue sa renommée en
dehors de tout principe la salle on en
parle ça nous parle comme des entités
qui sont aujourd'hui lointaine pour
chacun d'entre nous sert quand la
commissaire européen va négocier à
droite ou à gauche des accords qui
relève de notre soin de notre
souveraineté soit de notre besoin de
vivre ensemble méridienne well une vie
quotidienne bah on n'en sait pas grand
chose en fait on ne sait pas ce qu'elle
fait on ne sait pas avec qui elle parle
enfin on sait bien avec qui elle parle
mais on ne sait pas c'est qu'elle met
dans la balance et on ne sait pas ce qui
est négocié dans notre dos pour aller à
quels objectifs moi je me souviens très
bien par exemple une expérience
personnelle en tant que journaliste se
trouve que j'ai été j'ai couvert de
temps en temps des sommets de l' omc et
l'organisation mondiale du commerce en
2003 monsieur pascal lamy était
commissaire européen au commerce
devant moi il a dit que l'om c était une
organisation moyenâgeuse qui ne
pourraient pas fonctionner ou s'est
retrouvé monsieur pascal lamy quelques
années plus tard à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce en tant que
directeur général qu'est-ce qui se
nouent aujourd'hui au niveau mondial
nous n'arrivons pas à trouver d'accord
multilatérale a que font les
organisations ce soit les états unis la
chine la russie l'europe elle essaie de
trouver des accords entre elles entre
toutes ces nations où ces blocs essaient
de négocier des accords entre le
problème c'est que nous simples citoyens
on n'est pas tenu informé de tout ce qui
se passe on ne sait pas ce qui est mis
dans la balance
ça c'est un problème démocratique donc
notre boulot c'est d'aller me porter le
projecteur sur ces accords savoir que
pas savoir qui négocient pour la france
pour l'europe avec les américains
comment ça se passe le voilà c'est notre
boulot c'est d'aller là dedans et
présentait des pistes en ligne wikileaks
il ya quand même
1100 milles sur nathalie lanzi tu me
fait chuter ben m hidi kabyle pour nous
on est occupés ça c'est un rituel ces
derniers temps pas trop bossé mais il
faudrait qu'on bien sûr ça fait partie
des sujets bien sûr c'est un sujet
crucial le site si demain une heure une
entreprise comme google ou facebook peut
attaquer un état devant un tribunal un
truc et faire plier un état pour faire
passer ses intérêts économiques avant
les intérêts démocratique ça oui ça me
poser je pense que ça pose des problèmes
à jean-pierre mais ça pose des problèmes
à tout le monde aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas comment cette question en
particulier va être tranchée entre les
américains et les européens longtemps
les deux des pays c'est vraiment cester
qu'en fait tout à l'heure on disait quoi
on disait que finalement les états
aujourd'hui avec des moyens incroyable
pour connaître la réalité les états
public on connaître la réalité et puis
en face de ça on a des on a moins ce que
j'appelle des états privé voilà des
grands groupes qui aujourd'hui sont
dotées d'une police et deux parce qu'ils
ont joué sans supranationale oui les
puissances supranationale qui sont plus
fortes que beaucoup d'états bombe à ces
deux éléments mis l'un à côté de l'autre
devrait permettre à ce que nous la
puissance publique comprenions comment
ça se passe dans la sphère privée et
puissions réguler sa voie là bon il se
trouve qu'effectivement pour l'instant
au lieu de réguler on négocie en douce
du coup ça alimente le complot ça
alimente tous les fantasmes
nous ça nous procure du travail en a de
la chance mais c'est un travail
compliqué très très long très technique
qui nécessite de même parfois dont il
fait plaisir quoi non mais non justement
justement je vais traiter des chiens
écrasés non ok évidemment c'est un
plaisir intellectuel de travailler là
dessus mais bon
c'était espèce de vieille marotte qui
disent journalistes ils souhaitent y ait
des accidents pour les bambins très
honnêtement moi je suis d'abord citoyen
et non j'aimerais bien ne pas avoir à
passer sur le taffetas je dis ça
sincèrement et c'est peut-être propre à
moi je pense qu'il faudrait bosser sur
fois ci d'une baguette magique je te
donnais 2 millions d'euros pour les uns
faire ton documentaire tiré faire quoi
si avait pas de problèmes financiers je
te mets 2 millions sur la table là
vraiment tout de suite sur les paradis
fiscaux clairement parce que c'est à la
base de tout on partage des richesses
démocratie mais dans ma vie dit un sujet
couleurs 2 millions ça va faire chanter
pour les
habitudes de travail et que notre but
est de couteau vite et on fait des films
à 80000 euros 4 euros qu'avec de chaleur
on peut aller quand même beaucoup plus
loin j'en connais qui font des chaînons
48 heures c'est sûr mais là sur un mois
et demi on a fait quand même un ami
quand même bon je vais poser le dire je
vais poser une dernière question suis je
vais passer le micro à ma collègue de 10
en bourse
tu connais alors ça te paraître du but
en blanc comme ça mais on sûr sur notre
chaîne youtube on a des aficionados des
finances est-ce que tu connais le volume
des produits dérivés à l'heure actuelle
qui a dans le système financier non je
ne suis pas arrivé avec le chiffre en
tête mais par jour je dirais qu'on est
pas loin de 3000 milliards de dollars
alors d'après les dernières informations
que je tiens du think tank les écoles
classées de philippe béchade qui passent
sur bfm business qui est un petit peu le
père fouras
on approche quand même le million de
billard présidé le million de milliards
par quoi par jour par annie harley donc
si on divise je suis encore loin est-ce
que tu connais le volume de la dette
étudiante américaine elle est de
quasiment je crois que c'est 1000
milliards de dollars c'est ça un petit
quantitative easing est ce que tu
connais mais le pib américain s'est je
crois quelque chose comme ça dépend ça a
changé maintenant tu calcules pu enfin
bon bah c'est la prochaine bombe un an
yahoo les subprimes aujourd'hui la dette
américaine qui est détenu par les
étudiants c'est la prochaine bombe
financière c'est clair oui pourquoi mais
parce que si demain plus personne ne
peut rembourser toute la jeunesse
américaine qui se forment dans les
grandes écoles et qui doit rembourser
entre reparler en euros entrée parmi les
80000 euros par an 6 tous ces gens là ne
peuvent plus rembourser si les gens qui
rentrent sur le marché du travail ne
peuvent plus rembourser leur prêt
étudiant il ya énormément de choses qui
sortent qui s'effondre donc donc toi tu
attaquer comme ça la fleur au fusil je
reprends thème où l'habitat est habité
d'un couteau la banque qui fait un petit
peu d'évasion fiscale quand tu sais que
la crise des subprimes est un petit peu
d'argent sale des cartels qui ont permis
de redresser la tête de certaines
banques
tu te pointes comme ça et ait eu gratte
le vernis ça ne fait pas peur non voir
je dis moi où tu sais quand on attendait
de recevoir les gens étaient contents ce
que je veux dire c'est que on n'a pas de
louanges ont fait pas ça pour les
louanges d'abord on fait ça parce que
c'est notre devoir de journalistes
d'aller gratter et de révéler des infos
tout simplement tu connais les accords
de munich les accords ne veux tu parles
de qu'elle accorde mais l'idée est la
déclaration unique du journalisme ah oui
bien sûr de rien c'était plus que moi je
71 des journalises hausse en séance sous
les bancs bon allez une avant dernière
question je vous passe ma collègue vous
deux est-ce que vous avez des choses
encore à aborder tu penses que tu
voudrais discuter d'autre chose ou moi
je suis à votre disposition soit à
disposition alors je te revient tout
après un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
donne moi un conseil pour le dos à la
mer quand tu passes sur internet c'est
extraordinaire ouais à un conseil alors
j'ai peu de conseils à donner mais
simplement il faut s'accrocher quoi est
ce qu'ils ont envie de deux d'attaqué
le mont blanc par la face nord tout de
suite c'était à l'investigation pourquoi
pas c'est un domaine dans lequel on a
besoin de forces de besoin de cerveaux
jean-pierre disais tout à l'heure que on
est moins qu'on a plusieurs c'est vrai
qu'on est moins con à plusieurs sur la
place de paris il ya beaucoup aux
journalistes de sidaction mais depardon
d'investigation mais finalement si on
compare à la masse des gens qui sont
journalistes on est finalement assez peu
nombreux aa
a déterré a cherché à enquêter et à
faire ce boulot là donc moi je dirais
welcome moi je dirais ne culpabilisez ne
culpabilisez pas pardon d'être révolté
au sens et ses liens ou camusien du
terme
c'est bien d'être révolté c'est bien
après il faut rationaliser ça c'est à
dire que ça peut prendre plein de formes
dans le journalisme ça prend le travail
face et ça nécessite d'accumuler des
preuves pour prouver des choses et ça
sert à quelque chose au moins informer
les gens qui peuvent s'en emparer voilà
ça c'est du point de vue journalistique
et d'une manière générale n'ayez pas
mauvaise conscience à vous révolter
avoir un point de vue c'est la seule
manière d'exister sa seule manière de de
ne pas être ambigu et de savoir se
comporter face aux grands problèmes du
monde ça c'est important c'est ce que
disait le sait encore une fois ses
portes ouvertes mais personne ne le fait
stéphane hessel co rester ça révoltez
vous et au jeu indignez-vous pardon et
je pense que on est dans une
année dans une dans une période où il
est difficile d'assumer la révolte ou
l'indignation parce qu'on culpabilise
cette indignation cette révolte
immédiatement vous êtes un radical vous
êtes immédiatement sur la touche et ça
c'est important d'arrêter avec cette
mauvaise conscience on a tellement de
chantier dans le monde aujourd'hui
l'environnement la finance la protection
des sources le chiffrement voilà tout ça
sont des sondés terrain absolument
colossaux jamais aucun humain n'a eu
autant de chantiers aussi incroyable
face à lui donc la moindre des choses
c'est de se positionner bien entendu
groppi nous on a mis du temps avant
d'arriver à être un peu grande gueule et
révolté les gens il ya des gens ça se
construit ça prend ça prend du temps à
construire c'est cette envie cette
volonté de faire maintenant aujourd'hui
il ya un outil qui n'existait pas quand
on a commencé avec jean-pierre donc on
fait un peu vieux con mais c'est
internet et donc les jeunes et les
rations et ceux qui viendront derrière
nous ils ont intérêt à se saisir de ce
outils pour avancer et avancer
plus vite que nous qu'est ce tu entends
pas saisir l'analyse est un mac ou
sammarco des noms non s'il sera codée
c'est important il s'agit de savoir
coder et il s'agit de savoir utiliser
internet pour aller beaucoup plus vite
que nous que nous on est les dinosaures
encore par rapport aux gens qui savent
utiliser internet nous on a encore des
documents sur papier on va encore il
faut le cheval est permis c'est pas et
c'est pas je veux dire s'il faut pas
opposer les ni les sources et les
méthodes de travail mais c'est vrai que
berne et dans les années soixante dix
tous les deux on est dinosaures par
rapport à des jeunes de 25 ans qui ont
une connaissance de certains outils que
nous n'avons pas ça veut pas dire qu'on
se met pas à la page mais c'est vrai que
il ya cet outil là qui est
indispensable qu'il faut savoir faire
évoluer à mon avis mais d'ailleurs
là-dessus sur les sources qui est rigolo
c'est qu'il ya eu il ya 2 3 1 avec trois
quatre ans il ya eu beaucoup de frénésie
d'envoi des éléments sensibles aux
journalistes via les wikileaks les
frenchleaks etc
d'un point de vue numérique c'est à dire
on recevait vraiment des dossiers
numériques je veux dire quand et comment
il ya un petit retour en arrière gbagbo
il ya un truc tout bête une clé pgp par
exemple c'est intéressant c'est qu'en
mai fédéraux 10 millions de la voilà et
donc du coup maintenant comme les
failles sont assez
béante dans beaucoup de nos moyens
sécurisés d'envoi même si on a plein
d'autres on revient un peu à la old
school kwassa
documents papier le temps de great
technologies voilà nous on a reçu des
papiers on aurait pu les avoir sur
fichiers numériques finalement c'est pas
vraiment y avoir une clé mais dans on a
privilégié le papier parce que ça le
papier ne laisse pas de traces entre la
souris et nous il suffit savoir de le
récupérer le plus sécurisé que sécuriser
le plus sécurisé qui est je vous passe
pas comme ma claque de 10 ans dans ce
qui va se présenter puis vous reprendre
le mot de la fin
donc bonjour je m'appelle rina chez les
journalistes pour dissemblances donc
j'ai 16 ans je fais du programme âge on
sait donc je fais partie de cette
génération dont vous avez parlé kiné
avec l'internet qui va vivre dans le
futur avec l'internet et qui va comme
vous dites aussi bien lutté d'utiliser
j'espère c'est que de dons ah oui et
donc ma première question pour vous
c'est comment vincent pour le voleur est
au courant à de la diffusion de ce
documentaire dans une aussi grande
structure il est le patron
et un patron comme il le dit lui même
je paye je décide ce qui veut dire que
le patron de ce genre de groupe est
informé de tout ce qui se passe dans son
groupe et la structure même de canal+
c'est la meilleure note au monsieur
bolloré est arrivé à la tête de cette
entreprise est la mère dont il la gère
tout remonte vers lui et très rapidement
aucune décision n'est prise sans son
accord donc monsieur bolloré a été tenu
au courant très rapidement de la
fabrication et de la production d'un
documentaire qui le liait à quelqu'un
qui le qui est non seulement un
partenaire financier mais un ami c'est à
dire monsieur michel lecat le patron du
groupe crédit mutuel cic d'accord mais
vous l'avez t1
était indépendant le projet de ce
documentaire et c'est après que vous
avez proposé canal+ vous a proposé de le
diffuser à traction nous qui devons
reposer car nous sommes une boîte de
prod donc les boîtes de prod propose des
sujets aux chaînes de télé l'an
l'occurrence c'est pour la casse mais
ses investigations dans lequel nous
travaillons en travaillant depuis
longtemps et c'est nous qui l'avons
proposé il était très content parce que
c'est un beau sujet alors en fait on
imagine c'était assez naïf on
s'imaginait pas on n'a pas cherché les
liens entre le crédit mutuel et vincent
bolloré on a fait notre boulot quoi
vraiment on n'a pas cherché ces liens là
on a beaucoup travaillé sur le crédit
mutuel et sur la banque pasche en tout
cas ces liens là ne nous ont pas
empêchés de travailler on savait qu'ils
existaient on n'a jamais pensé que ces
liens la pouvait être une excuse ou
alors une envie vous pouvait représenter
un danger je ne sais pas pour monsieur
bolloré qui apparemment ont justifié une
censure en direct donc ça vous a
vraiment vraiment surpris quand bolloré
il a dit non ça peut pas être difficile
en fait ça s'est un peu censure à
l'ancien co reste à dire que c'est
extrêmement brutal c'est pas très très
honnêtement c'est pas très malin quoi
sert que vous arrêtez un film comme ça
vous êtes à peu près sûr lui donner un
écho énorme derrière c'est ce qui s'est
produit d'ailleurs c'est ce et c'est
pour ça qu'on était étonné aussi des
caisses pourquoi une telle une telle une
censure aussi brutale la direction de
canal + a même pas essayé de regarder le
film passeur a été quand même je pense
qu'on aurait trouvé une solution
d'ailleurs ils auraient regardé le film
il aurait vu que vincent bolloré était
pas été pas pris dans le dans le sujet
puisque c'était pas notre objet encore
une fois c'est pas parce qu'on se sent
sur elle parce qu'ils n'étaient pas dans
le sujet il est probable qu'ils auraient
peut-être décidé de diffuser des gens
sérieux mais c'est nous honnêtement
enfin moi je m'explique pas je pense que
toi non plus donc on s'explique pas
pourquoi ce coup de ciseau aussi brutale
aussi limpide on dira fabrice ars
mediapart dit que c'est une censure
chimiquement pur je crois qu'il a raison
c'est une censure chimiquement pur ça
faisait très longtemps qu'on ne l'avait
pas une une aussi belle en pleine nature
l'attaquant photo incroyable et on sait
ce qu'on se l'expliquent pas
complètement on a compris les liens d'un
terrain de le crédit mutuel est le
groupe bolloré mais d'un point de vue
purement stratégie de communication et
ça nous a servi puisque c'est gilles
compagnat rien pour le film c'était une
campagne de pub incroyable pour ce film
et il était pas gagné que ce film se
retrouve sur france 3 et heureusement
france télévisions nous a fait confiance
et s'est retrouvée sur france 3 et du
coup il ya eu un écho énorme dans la
presse évidemment le film a eu un joli
succès et donc s'il n'y avait pas eu
toute cette pub à travers la censure
vous pensez que vous avez vous aurez eu
combien de vue par rapport à ce que vous
avez maintenant vous avez aucune idée un
film qui marche bien sur canal+ en
crypté à 23h pour des abonnés donc ça
fait à peu près à pour un très bon film
entre 300 et 400 mille téléspectateurs
il se trouve que le précédent film qu'on
a fait ensemble avec jean-pierre sur la
famille mulliez qui détient auchan
décathlon et toutes ses enseignes que
vous connaissez bien a fait la meilleure
audience de l'année pour cette case là
qui est spécial associations et je crois
que c'était combien je crois que c'est
600 ou 700 unités de spectateurs 600 ce
qui est très bien pour canal je
vérifiais je rebondis sur cette question
vous avez proposé votre documentaire à
canalsat à accepter quand vous vous êtes
le camp vouloir tout qui vous avait
proposé à d'autres l'ajustement la
proposer à france télévisions sera tout
de suite tout de suite avec la corde
avec l'accord de notre chef notre chef
le plan b en suit le français les
visions fait et qui a le plan c es tu
veux dire non il avait il y avait deux
ou trois cases qui nous intéresse à
france télé on peut le dire il y avait
il ya évidemment pièces à conviction
dans lequel le sujet a été diffusé avec
h aussi cash investigations mais cache
instigation ça nécessitait un travail de
mise en route un peu plus long parce qu'
il fallait retourner des séquences avec
élise lucet et là nous on était inquiet
delà de la période de l'âme du caractère
périssable des informations ces
informations pouvait à l'époque on
pensait que que red action imminente de
la justice et donc on avait peur que nos
infos ne soit n'est plus un pacte
qu'elle devait avoir en étant diffusée
trop tard et donc pourquoi le csa a
laissé faire elle laissait faire tout ça
qu'elle commence à ces faits bonne
question arras et ça alors le csa le
sait ça c'est un cénacle de sage qu'il
qui ausculte le monde médiatique et ils
ont des prérogatives
ils ont des devoirs aussi
selon nous le csa devrait lancer une
enquête sur la manière dont monsieur
bolloré est intervenu au cours de l'été
dans différents dossiers pas simplement
le nôtre c'est-à-dire le sims au crédit
mutuel mais monsieur bolloré est
intervenu de manière directe et brutale
dans plusieurs dossiers est à mon sens
ça relève les prérogatives du csa et le
csa devrait mener une enquête et voir à
l'issue de cette enquête sanctionner la
gestion de monsieur bolloré
maintenant le csa fait ce qui lui plaît
c'est un organe indépendant
il se trouve que nous avons été reçus au
nom d'un collectif auquel nous
appartenons au jean pierre et moi qui
s'appelle informer n'est pas un délit
que ce collectif a été reçu donc par le
csa que nous leur avons exposé nos idées
nos revendications et maintenant c'est
au csa de travailler mais ce qu'on
attend du csa c'est qu'ils fassent
vraiment leur boulot qu'ils sanctionnent
s'ils doivent sanctionner monsieur
bolloré sur la base de textes qui
existent et le sait ça peut
enfin disons doit
regarder ses textes il doit prendre les
sanctions si monsieur bolloré selon le
csa n'a pas suivi cette réglementation
sous combien de temps le plus rapidement
possible c'est à dire que je mène
avec jean-pierre on a et d'autres nous
sommes donc allés au csa on les a
informés parce que jean pierre pernaut
fait partie de ce collectif non à de
notre collectif a encore imposé mais ce
formulaire klein mais jean pierre
bienvenu
d'abord tous les gens qui un prof
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses qu' il ya
une solidarité des journalistes qui sont
concernés par ces questions au sein du
collectif on est on est pas disent quoi
on est plusieurs dizaines en est on doit
être une grosse cinquantaine plus des
sdj non il ya aussi des gis donc c'est
pas nul ce sont des sociétés de
journalistes c'est une espèce d'organes
qui défend le le l'action journalistique
dents au sein des entreprises la sdj de
france télévisions qui va s'intéresser
non pas à l'aspect social mais à
l'aspect purement information et
protection d'informations au sein d'une
boîte donc ça prouve quand même que la
profession se bouger un petit peu
donc vous pensez que le ca ca havre mc
oui c est ça a vraiment une une
fondation pour pour par exemple suivre
le suivre en justice pouvoir le qu'est
ce que vous pensez à va être le résultat
si le csa a réussi à faire une
investigation plus profond alors le
processus de choix du csa et l'on nous
avons fourni des preuves toutes les
preuves de la censure sont entre les
mains du cs maintenant oui mais où mais
par rapport aux preuves c'est pas c'est
comme mon collègue à 10 et c'est la
surface vraiment et donc est ce que le
csa pourra
regarder en profondeur ce qui se passe
il peut regarder en profondeur il a tous
les éléments il peut et doit regarder en
profondeur doivent mais ce qu'ils font
haha ça
s'est calmé est ce que parce que si je
vole cinq cent mille euros que je paie
75000 euros qu'est ce qu'ils risquent
qu'est-ce qui avec un blâme au bout du
150e blâme il aura une contravention et
bout de la 200ème contravention il aura
peut-être
je ne sais pas une dictée à faire mais
évidemment que monsieur bolloré ne
tremble pas devant c'est ça si c'est ça
que vous voulez savoir le sait ça se
veut un point cash ou en fait ils se
battent à pour un cachou ils se battent
pour défendre des principes sains il se
trouve que nous on aimerait que le csa
incarne un peu plus ses principes et
qu'ils les fassent respecter que
monsieur aulas ne sera pas mis en prison
parce qu'il a censuré un film sur canal
plus et on ne demande pas que monsieur
bolloré aille en prison on n'a rien
contre monsieur bolloré simplement le
csa a tous les éléments vraiment tous
les éléments pour attester de la censure
de ce film est à tester d'autres
épisodes qui on puisse passer cet été il
ya un fait particulier quand même
concernant l'instant sur ce que l'on
parle de censure c'est que l'arsenal
juridique censure c'est une petite
obstruction de rien du tout à ma copine
à proposer tous les éléments de preuve
pour le dire donc les voies mais
juridiquement il est difficile de
qualifier la censure dire qu'en fait un
auteur comme nicolas moi j'étais rate
chef donc je ne vais pas auteurs
l'auteur nicholas vescovali journalistes
et sur le même plan vis à vis du
diffuseur qu'un auteur qui frère un
documentaire contemplative pas du tout
d'investigation sur un autre objet ce
qui fait que on a on peut on peut créer
on peut porter devant la justice
l'intervention sur le film sert une
coupe mais parce que ce serait de là ce
serait une remise en cause de l'acte
artistique en revanche qualifié la
censure ça n'est pas possible c'est
extrêmement compliqué d'un point de vue
auteurs donc tous leurs jeux dans quai
du csa la haye les deux lacs dans la
qualification de la reconnaissance de la
censure puisque pour une fois tous les
éléments de preuve sont sur la table
c'est ça l'enjeu sauf que pour qualifier
la censure juridiquement il faut une loi
il faut définir ce que c'est que la
censure et nous on est prêt à réfléchir
avec le csa et avec quiconque veut
réfléchir avec notre de ces questions
pour faire avancer les droits d auteur
des journalistes qui mène ce genre d'
enquête ce que c'est vrai j'aurais fait
un film sur les oiseaux à limoges
j'aurais pas été plus défendu et je
n'aurais pas eu plus de droits je ne
revendique pas plus de droits que les
autres mais je revendique sûr comme ça
plus de protection pour éviter qu'un
diffuseur une chaîne ou qui que ce soit
viennent s'interposer entre le reportage
que nous avons fait et la diffusion
c'est ce qui s'est passé sur canal +
d'accord donc je change un tout petit
peu de sujets donc renaud le van kim il
vous manque
mais renaud le van kim est en tout cas
il a été d'un bout à l'autre de cette
affaire courageux il a assumé tous nos
choix il nous a jamais lâchés il a il a
été par ailleurs le bon balaj ans la
victime d'un changement de cap de
vincent bolloré à canal et le crédit
mutuel n'est qu'un élément parmi plein
d'autres du vue de son éviction du grand
journal donc renaud le van kim à titre à
titre personnel je pense que nico est
d'accord avec moi oui nous le remercie
de son attitude comme patron de k m non
ils essaient pas renault c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est né pour
l'investigation il a d'autres choses à
faire dans la vie et voilà donc il nous
manque on le voit de temps en temps
quand même mais entre il fait plus
partie de notre combat parce qu'il a
autre chose à faire mais au delà il a
assuré le il a vraiment tenu son rôle au
moment où il fallait le faire c'est pas
si courant dans l'univers un tout petit
peu compliqué des médias on aurait pu
avoir un patron qui nous aurait lâché en
rase campagne tout de suite
ça on aurait pu le voir très facilement
on aurait pu avoir quelqu'un qui nous
lie écoutez les gars j'ai des intérêts
financiers industriels avec canal+ a été
nous embêter avec votre petit film sur
le crédit mutuel met de côté un vous
allez être payé de toute façon est
maintenant arrêtez avec votre histoire
ça sera plus exister ça arrive souvent
qu'on achète un sur documentaire pour le
faire taire on n'achète pas un
documentaire et ses 4es à millau où on
le met de côté et on évite que ça
embarrasse trop d'intérêts industriels
mais tu es payé les payer moi je suis
enragé t en contrat à durée indéterminée
j'aurais été payés pour fermer ta gueule
j'aurais été payée langues j'aurais été
payés pour faire ce film est au bout du
coup on producteurs auraient lâché en
rase campagne ce fils n'aurait pas été
diffusée et moi j'aurais pris mes
responsabilités je serais partie de la
boîte en connaît des sujets qui ont été
on va dire un petit peu traité comme ça
c'est à dire en gros ton fin limite
journaliste revient vers son rédac chef
en disant tu sais papa trans que j'étais
pas levé l'aï dit oui d'asie va
travailler mais un petit à petit 80000
euros sur la table y rentrer le fin
limier avec le renard dans la gueule
là son patron il dit écoute c'est
vachement bien ce que tu as fait on le
met au petit et archives c'est pas mal
t'inquiète pas on va sortir sa nouvelle
et ça ça non mais lui dit gentiment une
haie d'honneur il le dit le récit se
tourne il ya une heure il est bien sujet
il est livré la chaîne dit très bien
super sujet j'ai le sujet reste sur une
étagère il n'est pas diffusée voila
voila on censure ou alors il ya deux
lotos séance et une plus malin que de
dire à se rassurer l'autocensure marche
beaucoup mieux en fait moi je pense que
c'est assez incroyable essai été déclaré
comme ça l'autocensure marche beaucoup
mieux en fait pas besoin de censure et
je suis de s'auto censurer tout seul
comme ça ça passe beaucoup mieux il ya
moins d'intérêt mais s'il n'y a pas de
signes a pas de censure en général
l'autocensure vient d'où bd jean rhys
thomas liste mais oui mais s'il n'y a
pas de censure de base comment est ce
qu'un journaliste peut s'auto censurer
la taxe financière par exemple vous avez
la raison patron de m6 est pas longtemps
qui nicolas de tavernost qui a expliqué
sur un autre canal + qu'il fallait pas
embêtés des annonceurs
potentiels clients
donc voilà les annonceurs et clairement
il rapporte de l'argent la chaîne au
moins c'est clair c'est dit vous
travaillez dans une boîte de prod ou en
direct dans la chaîne et vous faites un
peu d' enquête on va déjà sauf si vous
avez un esprit rebelle incroyable où ce
que je disais tout à l'heure le fait de
se positionner comme journaliste sur un
sujet si vous aussi vous relâchez ça et
que vous commencez à calculer ma vous
vous dites bon tel sujet je vais pas le
faire là suis là non plus parce que
voilà je vais pas parce que je vais pas
me rapporter des emmerdes soyons clairs
quoi que c'est un combat ce métier voilà
non c'est un combat ce métier mais c'est
pas un combat d'anarchie ce combat le
républicain justement ouais il ya plein
de sujets qui sont ne sont pas faits qui
ne sont pas développés parce qu'on sait
que sur telle ou telle chaîne il s'agit
s'attaquait
ou de cibler un annonceur majeurs de la
chaînes
ça m'est arrivé
d'avoir sur une chaîne privée
des responsables éditoriaux qui me
disent écoute ton sujet et les super
merci de l'avoir écrit nous l'avoir
proposé mais malheureusement nous on
veut bien tenté de l'imposer mais je
sais quelle sera la réponse des
directeurs de la chaîne ce sera non
parce que tel ou tel sujet ne passera
pas puisqu'il s'agit d'un annonceur
majeurs de la chaînes ça ça existe alors
il ya des gens comme moi naïfs qui
proposent ce genre de sujet et puis y'a
des gens qui ne propose pas ce genre de
sujet parce que savent pertinemment que
ça ne passera pas c'est ça que j'appelle
l'autocensure oui oui je compense je
comprends merci pour la clarification
donc renaud le van kim c'est comme ça
que le prononçant voss a donc vous êtes
reconnaissants envers lui pour pour être
resté avec vous à travers cette
épreuve et ne pas avoir fui comme vous
et moi je suis non seulement sur koné
semble en plus on profite pour dissiper
une espèce de malentendus qui traîne
depuis plusieurs mois renault grand qui
n'est absolument pas à la base de notre
organisation pour diffuser ce film sur
france 3 ou de former les 50 de rien du
tout il a juste fait son boulot il a
laissé contactée une autre chaîne et
validé le fait de diffuser cette ce
documentaire sur une autre chaîne c'est
en ça qu'il a tenu son rôle serait déjà
très bien leur reste c'est nous qui
assumons nous tous on est une très
nombreux finalement sur cette affaire-là
et c'est une affaire aux journalistes
pour destination des citoyens
corporatifs bien sûr et donc qui paie
quoi aujourd'hui bon c'est pas trop il
avait annoncé la sincère quand il est il
va faire d'autres choses on sait pas
trop c'est une question qu'il faudrait
poser à lui on n'est pas inquiet pour
lui enfin il a quand même été dans cette
affaire pris à partie par un parent
plein de monde c'est un mec qui investit
pendant vingt ans dans dans son
entreprise et qui a été viré de son
entreprise
il avait lâché son départ et s'est fait
viré au bout de vingt ans de bons et
loyaux services
alors son entreprise il l'avait déjà
vendu un groupe important de médias donc
il en était devenu
salarié mais il a été quand même viré
manu militari par les interventions et
les coups de butoir de monsieur bolloré
qui dans le bras de fer dans le bras de
fer dans la bagarre a exigé la tête de
renaud le van kim et sa tête c'était
combien
chute dorée du monde je vais vous dire
un truc c'est simple
je connais pas le budget de ma boîte
j'en sais rien mais une émission
comme le grand journal qui était
produite par notre de production
s'avère un budget de 22 ou 25 millions
d'euros par an eh bien monsieur bolloré
a décidé que monsieur levante qui me
produirai plus grand journal broutilles
et donc ça a été un chiffre d'affaires
qui a disparu tout aussi rapidement que
la décision prise par monsieur bolloré
en plus c'est une décision qui est prise
dans début de l'été début de l'été dans
en télévision c'est un petit peu comme
le mois de novembre en saison de ski
quoi tout le monde est prêt à démarrer
et là d'un seul coup guim vous couper
tout le travail de dunes d'une émission
d'une boîte de prod qui avait embauché
des gens nous on a embauché des gens
pour faire de l' enquête d'un grand
journal gamme va embaucher une dizaine
de personnes petite dizaine de
journalistes pour faire de l' enquête
d'un grand journaliste gameiro nick
cette histoire et au passage je rajoute
qu'une émission comme le grand journal
que l'on peut apprécier ou que l'on peut
détester peu importe c'est pas la
question sa emploie une centaine de
personnes
principalement des intermittents du
spectacle tous ces gens là ont perdu
leur job en plein milieu de l'été alors
que ils avaient tous été reconduits
l'année d'après donc il ya eu une casse
sociale aussi importante il faut pas
l'oublier certains ont retrouvé du
boulot dans différentes émissions mais
certains n'ont pas beaucoup de boulot
donc il ya aussi cet aspect là des
choses qu'il faut pas négliger et j'ai
pardon pour ajouter un truc là dessus là
aussi parfois les gens et
d'investigation où on nous dit oui vous
êtes contre les entreprises vous allez
toujours à chercher des noises etc on va
pas d'avoir cherché des noises aux
entreprises à tort et à travers on y va
quand il ya du lourd et des gros sujets
nous notre but ce n'est pas de casser
des entreprises s'est essayé de montrer
au contraire le système pourrait être un
peu plus vertueux voilà la preuve c'est
que là nous en l'occurrence on a vu ce
que c'est de se comporter très
violemment dans le monde du business on
l'a vécu directement c'est pas florange
ans qu'on a vécu enfin quand même c'est
violent c'est du journalisme on va dire
avec un parti pris c'est alors modifier
aussi dit au journalisme d'opinion ce
que je veux mais je me mets au ris je me
mets en face toi tu dis tu dis un peu
plus juste un peu plus comment tu as
formule 1 juste respecter les règles
sont les mêmes pour tout le monde les
règles seront simplement être changé
mais les règles du moment en tout cas
les règles qui régissent ne résiste le
business et la vie sociale du moment
elles sont elle pourrait être pire on
est quand même dans un pays démocratique
castraise qui est très haut dans une
entité l'europe qui a quand même un
certain nombre de règles on n'est pas en
russie encore encore que
prend le chemin par mois pas paraphraser
un homme politique forcé mais moi je dis
oh moi j'aime l'entreprise aussi moches
les riches on adore les riches et les
hommes dans les procès les capitaines
d'industrie moi je les adore les pinots
les les arnaud les listes orange et je
les adore dont il est mort christophe de
margerie donc voila mais on adore tous
ces gens là mais en fait qui nous lâche
la grappe qui nous laisse bosser s'ils
n'ont rien à se reprocher
qu'on puisse travailler normalement 690
duke rinck ligue 1 ils ont investi du
pognon dans un secteur d'activité qui
perd du fric tout le temps et qui garde
quand même la main sur une activité qui
perd du fric tout le temps pourtant les
gars ils sont dressés à faire du pognon
depuis tout petit il garde la main là
dessus mais uniquement pour quoi oui
mais moi citoyen simplement pour faire
passer la communication corporate de la
boîte pour avoir moi je suis citoyen
lambda
ce que je veux c'est participer à la vie
collective à payer les impôts comme tout
le monde et essayer de mettre en place
quelques règles communes du vivre
ensemble alors ça c'est du baratin s'est
passé c'est tout ce qu'on vous dise
comment ridicule marque c'est essentiel
cm mais effectivement c'est essentiel
maintenant quand je regarde moi en tant
que citoyen les élites ce que je me
reconnais dans ses élites ce que je me
reconnais dans les méthodes de monsieur
bolloré de monsieur arnaud de monsieur
pinault ou de monsieur dassault le jour
où moi je me reconnaîtrait dans ces
grands capitaines d'industrie et leurs
méthodes à ce moment-là peut-être que
les choses auront changé un tout petit
peu mais s'ils n'ont rien à se reprocher
c'est qu'ils n'ont rien à craindre de
nous parce que nous on ne leur en veut
pas on n'est pas là pour les démonter et
les défoncer on est simplement là pour
mettre le doigt où ça fait mal quand il
ya des choses qui vont pas et le montrer
l'expliqué au plus grand public c'est
tout le reste
le reste on n'a pas de version améliorée
de la mouche du coche un peu les rouches
vous n'êtes pas la mouche du coche si
j'étais un petit peu du rail temps tu
dois te non tu doit jamais être
péjoratif par rapport à toi c'est à dire
que tu es le faucon l'oeil perçant tué
l'oeil perçant l'oeil perçant dois dire
de la démocratie c'est à dire que tu es
là pour être un petit peu un
contre-pouvoir comme tu l'as dit en
début d'interview mes respects à c'est
notre boulot
alors une dernière question puis ensuite
on va terminer parce que déjà ça fait
déjà longtemps deux dernières questions
très rapide
aujourd'hui du coup votre prochaine
enquête pour spécial investigation à ça
sera sur les dérivés de bolloré alors il
n'y aura pas de prochaine enquête pour
spécial investigation ce que pour le
moment vous l'aurez compris que ce sera
difficile pour nous de travailler pour
canal+ dans
ces conditions mais je veux dire votre
prochaine enquête les prochaines
enquêtes sont pas déterminées et le
financement de la prochaine est ce qu'un
creux de funding par internet un appel
directement si un géant taqwa pas si un
jour on a besoin 4,1 mio quand même
temps mais si on a besoin d'un jour des
gens qui vous regardent qu'ils nous
entendent sur internet on fera appel aux
dons si on a besoin de cette manière de
se financer
aujourd'hui pour le moment en tout cas
on n'a pas eu besoin mais j'ai des amis
qui travaille depuis très très
nombreuses années de cette manière là et
qu'ils financent leur documentaire de
cette manière là et pourquoi pas à me
dire
non mais pour simplement dire
qu'effectivement l'information à un coût
aussi
gratuit faut payer pour ça coûte de
l'argent de faire de l' enquête c'est
sûr et donc il nous faut des fonds pour
pouvoir travailler
à vous voulez vous pourrez aller à
disneyland avec vincent moulard valoir
vos l'aurait alors moi je pouvais aller
partout avec vincent bolloré sur son
yacht dans son avion privé à disneyland
sur une plage ya aucun souci kroum dont
vous mais j'irai n'importe où avec
vincent bolloré moi je j'adore vincent
bolloré est ce que je veux dire c'est
que on n'a rien contre eux vincent
maulay on n'a pas dent contre lui on
n'est pas là pour le lui casser du sucre
sur le dos on n'en fait pas des cibles
tous les matins on n'a pas une cible
avec le visage de monsieur boulot on
lance pas des fléchettes et
donc on n'a rien contre lui est ce que
vous n'avez rien contre lui mais si vous
l'aviez en face de vous là juste là
qu'est ce que vous voulez me thiriez
entre je vais demander pourquoi il a
censuré ce chinois je veux débattre de
cette question avec lui oui mais ça ça
je pense qu'on peut tous déduire de ce
qui s'est passé qu'il a des intérêts
peut-être dans l'ue - ouais oui vous lui
demanderez mais vous personnellement
vous non moi je vous dirais je vous
dirais que à posséder un média alors ok
maintenant internet viens viens proposer
des nouvelles formes de médias enfin je
veux dire de moyens d'enquêté on en a
cité un trailer mediapart mais quand
même les grandes chaînes de télé non ça
reste des grands vecteurs d'information
il ya une responsabilité à avoir un
média on traite pas un média comme un
produit normal en fait parce que ça
implique l'une des valeurs fondamentales
de la démocratie pardon employer les
grands mots qui est la liberté
d'informer le droit à l'information
donc il ya un droit à l'information dans
un grand média une grande chaîne de
télévision donc on ne peut pas se
comporter comment se comporte avec j'en
sais rien moi le l'huile de palme ou
d'une entreprise de boulons c'est tout
c'est l'information c'est une ça n'est
pas qu'un produit c'est ça aussi une
valeur fondamentale d'un pays donc on ne
gère pas une chaîne de télé comme on
gère une usine d'un produit classique en
même temps ils doivent alors fait moins
parler avec lui en fait voir aussi bien
gérer les usines de boules enfin il
s'agit pas de mal géré a nommé ce que
j'ai dit c'est juste sinon c'est vrai ça
soit clair bien sûr qu'une plantations
d'huile de palme doit respecter aussi
des normes doit respecter ses salariés
mais chez bolloré à 83 mille hectares de
plantations de par le monde il doit
respecter les gens qui travaillent tout
autant qu'il respecte ses personnels à
paris donc ils viennent quand même c'est
le premier aspect là
la chaîne a mis la raison l'a jamais
acquis et elle est un mélange de mesures
enfin il a raison la chaîne de télé
c'est déjà un premier point puis ensuite
la grande question qui se pose c'est
peut-on
posséder un grand média qui fait de
l'information et en même temps avoir des
activités ailleurs susceptibles d'être
contre enquêtait parce par ce média
c'est une vraie question c'est pas pour
l'embêter c'est une vraie question voilà
et donc c'est quoi le média de vos rêves
je suis parent pour couper mais c'est
l'essence mais c'est toujours de
l'utopie qui peut se transformer en
entrée grand magic l'enfer est pavé de
bonnes intentions mais je suis assez
d'accord avec ça je crois que c'est un
média qui a
d'abord qu'à trouver un moyen de
financer ces enquêtes pardon je vais
décrire mediapart c'est pas trés le
slogan médias par ses seuls nos lecteurs
peuvent nous acheter je trouve ça pas
mal comme comme slogan parce
qu'effectivement ils ont résolu
plusieurs problèmes on paye pour avoir
d'information paie parle trop il ya
aussi des prix adaptés aux chômeurs aux
gens aux étudiants encore moins d'argent
la rédaction est assez cohérent je
connais pas les subtilités de mediapart
c'est sûrement des problèmes comme
ailleurs mais la rédaction est assez
cohérente on est tourné vers du
journalisme de fonds
j'espère qu'il n'y a pas de lien pas de
connotation politique c'est à dire que
je pense qu'on enquête que tout le monde
qu'on peut enquêter sur dans tous les
domaines y compris contre des gens de
droite de gauche des industriels ou des
ou des syndicalistes ou enfin toute la
société sans parti pris je crois que je
crois que c'est le cas à mediapart et à
partir de là on est dans une rédaction
qui quand même pas mal c'est bien la
rédaction idéal je crois pas qu'il
existe on est des humains donc et des
tiraillements forcément bien d'ailleurs
mais qu'aurait bien mais quand on est
dans un monde avec des restrictions et
des choses donc quand tu on vous
recherchez quelque chose qui est qui est
un peu bon dangereux ça mais ça bloque
vous êtes d'accord mais c'est avec ces
avec ce blocage que vient le buzz et que
les gens entendent parler de cette
enquête que vous êtes passé et donc s'il
n'y avait pas ce blocage est ce que vous
pensiez donc justement ça revient la
question que vous avez posé avant ci
avait pas ce blocage combien de gens
réellement auraient regardé ce document
moitié moi je sais pas à peu près moitié
moins non mais la série black mirror le
les griottes 2 de la saison un monde à
aller voir ça va sur la télé réalité la
question c'est est-ce que le
divertissement fini par l'emporter au
final surtout est ce que l'information
ait compris des révélations forte mais
ne révèle pas la fin ça c'est
intéressant la fnam et justement fini
par l'emporter est ce que l'esprit de
divertissement philippaerts couronner
tout ça et on nivelle tout de
l'investigation joindre au dossier la
météo une télé réalité ce que tous a eu
ni blessés là c'est ça la question
et ben moi je crois pas en fait je suis
un peu naïf mais je crois pas je crois
je crois qu'on en fait ce qu'on en veut
le problème c'est le trop plein
d'informations et l'incapacité que nous
avons tous
j'emmagasine et et c'est difficile il ya
un dossier chaud toutes les heures donc
je crois pas que les citoyens soient
complètement des conscientiser tout ça
simplement c'est difficile de prix
d'avoir des priorités sur quoi est ce
que je vais j'ai une journée de boulot
normal à assumer j'ai une famille à
nourrir est-ce que derrière je dois
m'engager où je devais être élu je dois
aller à méditer dans une association
écolo je dois au contraire faire en
sorte que mon entreprise parce que je
suis patron d'une entreprise soit soit à
la fois performante et redistribue bien
la richesse sur les salariés c'est cette
voie là moi je crois que les gens sont
pas que dans le divertissement je crois
pas que nivet mon soi permanent
simplement il ya un trop plein qui fait
qu' on ne sait pas quoi choisir j'en
suis là mais réflexion durcir l'esprit
critique pour apprendre à discerner
l'information de la contre information
ouais ouais on est plutôt hors bilan
était bien que le robinet est très très
ouvert qui laissait pas qui fuient la
sécu c'est la grosse goutte et du coup
nous on essaye d'apporter notre petite
pierre avec nos petits sujets c'est les
petits cailloux ou qu'elle a choisie
joueuse j'avais vu la joueuse mais par
rapport à des grosses machines c'est sûr
qu'on importe peu maintenant je crois
qu'on apporte des infos d'intérêt
général et ça c'est indispensable a dit
jean et porte la place publique c'est
déjà pas mal
j'espère que ça sert à quelque chose
j'en suis pas sûr heureusement déjà il a
encore des gros sujets que vous avez pas
encore traité également aujourd'hui sur
sa part ça c'est sûr si sur le système
financier si vous êtes chauds où on peut
vous aider on vous remercie pour cette
interview on vous conseille de regarder
monsieur robot ça vous ça vous aider un
peu vous sécurisez vous vos diverses
numérique et on vous dit peut-être la
prochaine fois avec denis rabaglia qui
vous passe le bonjour qui n'a pas pu
être là ce soir parce qu'il fait son
film les présente son fils au mexique
sur un carré d'as il serait très heureux
de vous rencontrer lors d'un prochain
tournage je vous remercie ex en journée
merci
et
on